agents we've recovered five of the
hostages taken in the attack on the
White House but with each member of our
community we learn Natalia Sova is not
the murderous psychopath we assumed I
don't know if it's General Anderson's
influence over her organization or if
spending her life on the move is getting
to her but it appears that the black
task have adopted the true son's tactics
and are looking to shore up
infrastructure and build something what
that something is it's too early to tell
without Vic as Mari says he knows her
organization he helped build it agents
if we want to rebuild the castle and
know what Circle over is really up to we
need to get Vic and unmasked the
asset